thank you
[Music]
so some uh only fans lawyers
accidentally reveal which meta AKA
Facebook execs allegedly to bribes
bribes who was it
when adult entertainers initially filed
a lawsuit alleging that only fans bribed
meta to block competitors on Instagram
by flagging their content as terrorism
it was not clear who at meta was being
accused of accepting bribes let me
repeat that for everybody out there do
one more time when adult entertainers
filed a lawsuit alleging that only fans
had bribed meta to block competitors on
Instagram by flagging their content as
terrorism it was not clear who at meta
was being accused of accepting the
bribes so it's adult entertainers trying
to get the other adult entertainers off
of meta out of business it's actually
the adult entertainers that are seeing
that old me fans in general as energy
bribed meta AKA Facebook as an entity
to block their competitors on Instagram
by flagging their content as terrorism
um saying and they're basically saying
these people have meta were uh accepting
those bribes for for you know
aka the people who were blocked yeah
yeah
um but that changed this week when
lawyers for only fans owner uh Phoenix
International Limited accidentally filed
a court document that mistakenly failed
to redact the names
allegedly connected to the global
conspiracy yeah
it's that blatant a bark a fluckerberg
that's like five names but they're all
like that
Wharton brooch fluckerberg I will now
read the five different things because
of the misstep it's been revealed that
adult entertainers have specifically
accused three meta employees of taking
bribes the employees are Nick Clegg met
as vice president of global policy
Nikola Mendelson vice president of the
global business team and Christian
pereiria or whatever whom Yahoo finance
reported is meta's European safety
director
according to the Aaron Court filing
which was only fans second attempt to
push the court to dismiss a lawsuit
lawyers for plaintiffs suing meta and
only fans received an email with a
document titled quote follow the money
end quote through a confidential tip
line the document allegedly shows that
Phoenix wired money to Clegg Mendelson
and perea suggesting that these wires uh
that these wire transfers provided
evidence that the meta employees
accepted the bribes Phoenix and only
fans did not immediately respond to
ars's request for comment but their
lawyers argued in their motion to
dismiss that the plaintiffs hid the
identity of the tipster because of that
Phoenix suggested that the court cannot
verify the authenticity of the quote
followed the money document without the
identity of the person who sent the
email it is impossible to assess the
believability of the consents of the
email of the contents of the email their
motion to dismiss reads so in essence
three Facebook executive or sorry meta
new phrasing in 2022 three meta
Executives were caught
accepting bribes by only fans they're
just claiming that it's only fans in
general not just uh adult entertainers
in order to block certain people and
assist other you know uh what's the
what's the official amount of times
I understand there's way too complex tag
team Jason explained it for everybody
bulldozing him now
so um what what the article is everybody
is
um you should explain it really well go
ahead I think you explained it great
yeah I really think so too but I think
so what happened
so what happened was that is I I really
feel like the the only fans people
they're very it's really nice that
they're they just want to win no yeah
they're blocking out other foreign
companies yeah is that bad but like
browsers you're gonna Stick it to you
it's not the best business practice I
see it you read it so well that I
understood
I did too congratulations to me you know
so much so that I can explain it so well
yeah okay it's basically this all right
let's say Bart is meta AKA Facebook
right no I got it let's say me yeah I
got it the first time dude it's for Nick
this is for Nick I know you get it I
know you fully comprehend 100 okay
you're so good you're probably 120 right
okay right but for people like Nick okay
who only understand 50 okay basically
let's say me I do only fans and you do
only fans okay but I look at you as a
competitor yeah and then you so I'll be
like hey Bart
I'm Gonna Give You fifty thousand
dollars and can you block him on
Instagram saying that his terrorism
now you're blocked you can't promote
your [ __ ] yeah
that's exactly what you I know you
understand that Nick didn't understand
that that's what I wanted him to
understand
do you see what I'm saying yeah no
comprehension because I don't watch it
this is the part where you Rift now I'm
done with the article now go ahead man
kill it all right Nick you want to talk
about that you're you're also a good
buffer no because is this on patreon
uh so the only fans people
um just wanted to do good business but
also just be a little bit of a snake
yeah which should be a little Cricket
but you know some people do business the
right way yeah but sometimes they don't
succeed do you feel like only fans needs
to even block other companies well in
the beginning they might because nobody
knows all the fans and they're like you
know what so that's true so just for the
situation that I know you fully
understand okay well why'd you say three
times though because it's the content
creator on only fans Not only fans right
yeah well that's the question so again
back to our analogies he's he's meta
slash Facebook yes we're two only fans
and you pay I'm paying him right to
block me who's in trouble me me or him
no oh okay well I'm in trouble because
you're I'm became blocked yeah yeah but
you're okay you're innocent okay but
you're both in trouble is the thing but
mostly who's most in trouble whoever
that is taken abroad because usually
that's what how it works yeah you gotta
get rid of the Bride people because if
it's on them to be like a neutral ground
right no no I can't do that I can't do
that but then also you like you're the
director of safety I like money you like
money so what in your opinion is the uh
what we like to call here in JK news the
Poetic Justice what do you feel is the
appropriate consequence for the people
that did wrong
murder oh jeez no why what
um what just uh like him well how about
this how about how about like um
you know because only fans are really
big now and and The Meta is like hey
only fans are really big and then I'm
trying to come up too and then but then
I was blocked so they're saying you're
[ __ ] terrorists I know but now you
are both like I'm sorry you know and
then now you let me you promote me a
little bit
so that's it all you're looking for is
an apology and then we promote you and
then maybe like a settlement
how much what but but you you want to
take a selling but you're not going to
take anybody out of their position
everybody you're not firing anybody what
there's just too much because that if
you want to do this if you want to go to
court there's just too much money and
maybe I don't have money and he has too
much money and then I go please can I
just have some money but what if you sue
me for enough money forget about this
then it's worthwhile I assume you for
100 million and then the [ __ ] civil
lawyer because I can't afford a good
lawyer then she'll go oh we have to
settle for a thousand dollars is that
okay and I go [ __ ] know a thousand
dollars it's a dollar settle they always
give you like a crazy the Civil War
because I can't afford it really all you
civil lawyers if you're not great no but
I thought they give you us a lawyer sure
right when you can't afford one yeah
yeah and then but quarter pointed
lawyers that don't take payment until
they win for you too I love them so you
find one of those guys I'm one of those
guys if I get 100 million get 100
million but they take 45. yeah that's
like 50 of it yeah of course
I would like it yeah that's sweet okay
but then I feel but no no but meta is so
but meta will probably just like pay
another person like hey don't work with
him you know why why men you don't think
there's a female lawyers
we said
uh oh or her or no really there's
there's really no feelings
whoever let's get political yeah yeah
yeah sure yeah so that they could um
uh everybody could have a good time
but but at the end of the day it is
really messed up though
everybody's gonna have a good time has a
good time here in court it is really
messed up that they block you know they
block their first how do you how do you
feel about situations like this because
obviously it's not the first time that a
major executive is accepting bribes in
order to kind of like you know
I just feel like everybody do the
snacking snakes and then everybody oh
well a lot of people in business because
sometimes it's like gray area
snake and snake into are you one of
those people let's say let's say that
you had um again I don't want to be
Blasphemous but let's say you're at the
hand of God and you could deal death and
judgment are you accepting that everyone
if everyone participates in the snakey
snake we're okay or are you like if
somebody gets caught in my justice
system I want to put maximum penalty and
uh exact an example so that things get
better where are you it seems like
that's what you want no I'm asking you
what you want
no that's that's good too is the thing
hey Nick take note take note that was
good that was a good one that was a
really good question right yeah I'm
Gonna Learn better I'll be better
um what sometimes is good but because
sometimes it's so complex I feel like
and uh sometimes you let them slide and
sometimes people go no why'd you let
them slide 30 years later and sometimes
they go well right now don't let them
slide and people are like yeah I don't
let this fly and then
and then every time it's a little
different
sometimes you got a little
slow you can't that's what you're saying
yeah and sometimes people are just too
powerful you know and um what would you
do in a situation if let's say there's a
the person who's booking Netflix is a
joke festival and they go to you and the
guy goes hey
roster's full bite if you give me 150
bucks I'll get you on there would you
pay that 150 bucks it's only 150 15 what
about 1500 150 bucks I'll give you two
hundred dollars what are you talking
about right now but it's still bribery
whether it's 1500 or 150 the crime's
still the same thing yeah of course
so that's okay to you no it's not okay
but a lot of practices a lot of what it
could be like in the form of like gift
giving for example it's Christmas time
oh you're like hey don't don't bribe me
no that's what it's Christmas it's
Christmas time we'll take an undisclosed
bonus yeah exactly so I'm walking to the
eggnog right and then I bump into for
example
um a Christmas tree and I go oh [ __ ] in
the money flyer
onto the Christmas tree whose money is
that I don't know because I'm drunk off
of eggnog you know and then and then
maybe the owner find the money and they
go oh I think this is from Jason and
then I go I don't know I'm drunk right
now why would they know that they say
they it might they like Jason was
it's Christmas party that's right yeah
the perfect cover and that's not bribing
to you no it is
[Laughter]
undisclosed driving but not uh on paper
I don't think when is snaky snake not
acceptable to you
when it I feel like um was such a
there's no definite line it's so hard to
say a definite line but uh maybe someone
paid money to get you off the roster and
them on yeah that's really messed up but
that happens all the time and sometimes
sometimes but sometimes I just say hey
God this happened to me there's another
window that might be closed as well
just be sad but then maybe the door will
open later and I go out that door I go
you know what Jesus take the wheel and
I'm home you know so yeah that's a good
catchphrase
[Music]
[Music]